[Music]
I'm great professor of Electrical
Engineering and president emeritus and
it is my great pleasure to welcome all
of you this evening to the fifth Ford
Motor Company MIT Nobel laureate lecture
the Ford Motor Company has sponsored now
for this is the third year these
lectures and we are much appreciative of
that support as you know from the from
the program announcement our subject
tonight is global environmental issues
effects on the atmosphere and the
biosphere our first speaker is Professor
Mario Molina professor Molina is an
institute professor at MIT if you're not
familiar with that title there are at
any one time fewer than 12 individuals
who are elected by their faculty peers
to be institute professors and they have
the freedom of the house so to speak
they are no longer confined to a
department or a school but may pursue
their interests wherever it leads them
professor Molina came to MIT in 1989
with joint appointments in the
Department of Chemistry and in the
Department of Earth atmospheric and
other planetary sciences he shared the
1995 Nobel Prize in Chemistry for his
work on the chemistry of the ozone layer
and the effect of CFCs chlorinated
floral carbons on the ozone layer his
interest now involved the chemistry of
air pollution of the lower atmosphere in
particular the problems of rapidly
growing cities and those of you who have
traveled recently to Mexico City you are
Bangkok or Beijing will know what that
problem
is I should announce if you didn't see
it in tech talk today that Professor
Molina was a recipient of the Heinz
award just a few days ago for his work
in the understanding in understanding
and mitigating effect meaning at
mitigating effects on air pollution and
advocating changes in public policy as
they bear on air pollution our second
speaker tonight is Professor Eric Shiv
Ian dr. Shivan was co-founder of the
organization called international
physicians for the Prevention of nuclear
war an organization formed some 20 years
ago about the time
dr. Shivan joined the MIT staff as a
physician in our medical department that
group the organization received the
Nobel Peace Prize in 1985 dr. Shivan is
now director of the Center for Health
and global environment at the Harvard
Medical School and his interests include
the human health consequences of habitat
degradation species extinction and
biodiversity loss now our plan for this
program is that each of our speakers
will speak for some time at the lectern
and when they are both finished they
will move to the table and we will
entertain questions from the audience
please join me in welcoming professor
Molina and dr. Shivan
[Applause]
thank you very much professor pray for
your kind introduction it's a pleasure
for me to be here tonight as part of
this for them I teach Nobel laureate
lecture series and to share the podium
with my colleague at achievement I would
also like to thank all of you for being
here in spite of the weather we have
tonight
maybe I'm presumptuous and you are all
here because you got trapped with the
snow but I'm an optimist I want to talk
tonight about global environmental
issues so let me start with this
overview of the sort of issues that we
are concerned about these are just
examples all right but I want to point
out is we have two types of issues
completion of Natural Resources that
includes issues such as loss of
biodiversity and so on disposal of
hazardous waste water pollution air
pollution and so on but we have another
set of issues that I label global and
what's happening is that the ich the
first set of issues we normally consider
to be local or regional what has been
happening in recent years
is that these problems are happening in
so many places on our planet that
they're beginning to acquire global
proportions the second set of issues are
truly global in scope because there are
consequences of changes in the
composition of the atmosphere truly on a
global scale so I'm going to say a few
words about these aspects of
environmental problems that have to do
with the atmosphere I think Eric will
talk perhaps more about some of the
biological effects to put that in
perspective show you this picture of our
planet from space we're dealing with the
atmosphere and what you really see
from the atmosphere itself is just the
clouds the atmosphere is transparent as
you know but the point I want to make
here it's very thin it's like like the
skin of an apple and that's why on a
scale of human activities it we can
explain how is it that we are changing
the composition of this very important
system another reason why this is
happening is that there are certain
components of the atmosphere that we
label trace gases that are present in
parts per million or even parts per
billion levels very small amounts but
those are the ones that have important
consequences for the behavior of the
atmosphere itself the all constituents
nitrogen and oxygen are fairly inert in
many of these physical and chemical
respects so I'm going to start talking
about one of those problems that relates
to a layer of the atmosphere that we
cannot see here which is the
stratosphere before that I want to point
out another feature of this skin if you
want this very thin layer and it is the
timescales for mixing there are certain
chemical compounds that when released to
the atmosphere are very rapidly removed
from the atmosphere by the cleansing
mechanism that we have many of them are
related to the presence of clouds for
example rain removes many pollutants
there are however other compounds that
last days months or even years in the
atmosphere the timescale for mixing
within each hemisphere is of the order
of months that means if you release some
compounds that are sufficiently stable
to remain in the atmosphere for months
of years they will be rapidly mixed
within each hemisphere mix him between
the two hemisphere takes a little longer
the timescale is between a year or two
so let me move on to this problem oops
this problem that the first one that I
will deal with which has to do with a
ozone layer that our planet has what we
have here is just a typical ozone
profile at the choice concentration of
as a function of altitude and also on
this also Alerus exists in the
stratosphere which is the second layer
above the Earth's surface the
troposphere is below as I just mentioned
mixing in the troposphere occurs in
pretty fast horizontally a timescale of
months but the same thing happens on the
vertical scale mix if you release
species close to the Earth's surface it
only takes weeks or months for them to
be rapidly mixed throughout the
troposphere but in the stratosphere
mixing occurs much more slowly and
that's because temperature increases
with altitude in the stratosphere
coracii decreases with altitude in the
troposphere that's why as we go to
higher altitudes gets colder and colder
so consequence of those temperature
profiles is these timescales for mixing
now we worry a lot about the ozone layer
because it has a several very important
functions one in fact I just mentioned
the fact that temperature increases with
altitude and sets up the properties of
the atmosphere that's a consequence of
the presence of ozone which by the way
is one of those trace constituents are
you saluted to its present only a parts
per million levels
what's the trace on earth also nice very
unstable species but it's a presence
there
the consequence is two to give this
increasing temperature profile and
that's because also an absorbs
ultraviolet radiation from the Sun that
would otherwise reach the Earth's
surface and have very important
biological effects some of that
ultraviolet radiation at wavelengths
between about 290 and 3 20 nanometers
what we call biologically UVB or the
biologically active ultraviolet region
that penetrates to the surface to some
extent depending on how much ozone you
have overhead but the point is that this
is a very important component of a huge
natural system now what we have learned
just in the past few decades the
research I started together with my
colleague sherry Rowland in the 1970s is
that there are certain industrial
compounds that we
no we know as CFCs chlorofluorocarbons
these compounds are not natural they
were developed industrially to replace
toxic compounds like sulfur dioxide and
ammonia for uses such as refrigeration
and they have several sets of properties
one is that they can be readily
converted from liquids to vapors and
that's what you need in a refrigerator
they are also useful to make for example
plastic foam like when you're sitting on
or as propellants in spray cans all
these use is required in this conversion
of a liquid to a vapor and and vice
versa second properties are relatively
simple to make and hence relatively
cheap and that's why they could be
manufactured in large amounts
industrially what the third property
features is also very important is that
they are chemically very inert you can
even breathe them in contrast to the
gases I'd replaced like ammonia and
sulfur dioxide you can breathe them like
you do when you use a spray can or at
least that's what used to be the case in
the past now what we suggest that in the
1970s is that the use of these gases
would have important consequences which
are summarized in this cartoon here what
happens because of the chemical
stability these compounds are not
removed by this natural cleansing
properties that the atmosphere has
they're not soluble in rain and so on
but they can actually move to the
stratosphere this is mixing here just
takes a few months but here it takes
several years and eventually when they
move above the ozone layer they find the
type of radiation that the ozone layer
itself yields and that's what breaks the
molecules apart releasing very reactive
compounds that we call free radicals and
through an amplification factor
catalytic cycles they can indeed affect
ozone levels so a single chlorine atom
can actually destroy many tens of
thousands of also molecules and that's
why even if you have only parts per
billion levels of CFCs all of these
compounds you you can have significant
effects on also so this was a prediction
in the early 1970s many Experion
we carried out and eventually it became
clear that something indeed was
happening to the ozone layer and of all
places for the effects were most
spectacular happened to be over
Antarctica as far as possible from the
sources these compounds were mostly
released in the northern hemisphere and
what we have here is a normal looking
awesome profile very similar to the one
I just show you a few minutes ago and
that was measured with balloons early in
the spring the light was just coming out
in this year over at Arctica after the
long polar night and on a timescale of a
couple of points you can see that you
develop this breath profile namely had
so multitudes more than 99% of the ozone
was gone
so this is the consequence of this type
of catalytic cycles I was mentioning it
and these altitudes coincide with the
presence of all of those very clouds I
won't have time to go into the details
of the chemistry that are very very
interesting but let me just point out
that this very spectacular effect occurs
mostly at high latitudes also course
over the Arctic although perhaps not
quite as spectacular but it became clear
that awesome was being depleted not just
over the post but admit latitudes as
well and what happens what happened as a
consequence of these findings and
scientific community working together
and making a very strong scientific case
namely that the CFCs were decomposing in
the stratosphere and in turn be
composing also on there was an
international agreements called the
Montreal Protocol first enacted in in
1987 but then strengthened that led to a
total ban in the industrial production
of CFCs by the end of 1995 this pan
happening only in the industrialized
countries but even somewhat longer
timetable for the developing countries
to eventually banned the CFCs as well so
this is the first instance of it truly
international agreements that we believe
has actually worked and we can show that
here this is the set of measurements
from one of the CFC CFC eleven by this
alga
program which is coordinated by my
colleague Ron Prinn the heaps apartment
and you can see here this very rapidly
industrial growth of industrial
production of this compounds led to
increasing atmospheric concentrations of
this compound until it became clear that
the Montreal Protocol was going to take
effect and around this time then
industry essentially stopped producing
these compounds except for this smaller
amounts in the developing countries and
so you could see how it's the
concentrations slowly coming down what
happens is it will take quite a few
decades for these concentrations to come
down because of the stability of these
compounds implies that they will remain
in the atmosphere for many decades
because of this we do not expect the
ozone layer to recover immediately it
would take several decades more before
we see for example he also on hole over
Antarctica is up here but anyhow this
turning around in what is a global
property of the atmosphere a consequence
of of an international agreement is the
first instance that we have of such an
impact I shall come back briefly to this
problem you know if I have time but
first I want to to discuss briefly yet
another problem which has to do with
climate change and perhaps make some
analogies with the problem of ozone
depletion and the problem of climate
change were worried about it also
because the chemical composition of the
atmosphere is changing
truly on a global scale the problem has
to do with the energy balance of our
planet and what we know happens in terms
of energy is that our planet receives
energy from the Sun but it's essentially
steady-state has been so formally
mimicked millions of years
it loses essentially the same amount of
energy as it receives from the Sun and
those amounts of energy in this chart
here are represented by the areas under
these curves which have to do with
intensity of the radiation
a function of wavelength or coal or if
you want so we receive energy from the
zone a good fraction of which is in the
visible that's why our vision developed
to have maximum sensitivity for visible
light what our planet loses this energy
of much longer wavelengths in the
ultraviolet now I have here several
equations which I will not explain in
much detail but I put them here for
historical reasons these equations those
of you that are physicists Organists or
engineers will probably recognize them
they were developed at the beginning of
the 20th century they were extremely
important there was a revolution in
physics that led to the development of
quantum mechanics and so on that name
such as Albert Einstein or Max Planck
are associated with these equations so
they had an enormous impact on on the
development of science but it just so
happens that a plant's equation also
describes the shape of these curves so
this is very fundamental science and in
principle we can use these equations to
predict what should be the temperature
of our planet all we have to know is how
much energy would you see from the Sun
how far is our planet from the Sun and
essentially also the color of our planet
and if we do this realizing the Sun is
around 57 on ridiculous and degrees we
calculate that the earth should be at
minus 18 degrees something and again
these are very fundamental equations in
principle there's nothing wrong with
them but there's something wrong with a
number if we really have an average
temperature in our planet of minus 18
the oceans would be frozen we wouldn't
be here so there's something that
requires explanation
what as experimentalist we can see what
else is going on
in our solar system the moon on the
average is at the same distance from the
Sun as the earth and indeed the moon on
the average is at minus 18 degrees
centigrade so the calculation was all
right
however if you look a little bit more in
detail it turns out that on the sunny
side the moon is at a hundred degrees
and degrees on the dark side that - 140
degrees and degrees so on the average
it's indeed minus eighteen nice weather
fortunately the earth but here as an
atmosphere okay so the atmosphere plays
a very important role in terms of
distributing this energy but that still
doesn't explain the average temperature
that we should have but we have another
example in this case we go to Venus
Venus is you know closer to the Sun this
is a picture of Venus in the ultraviolet
because in the visible Venus is very
white that's why you can see it's so
bright in the sky so it turns out that
the amount of energy absorbed by Venus
the amount of energy coming from the Sun
is smaller than the amount of energy
that our planet absorbs in spite of that
the surface of Venus is very much warmer
it's around 470 increase and increase
okay warmer than a hot oven and so this
is because the atmosphere of Venus in
contrast to our atmosphere here on earth
it's very heavy and it consists mostly
of carbon dioxide so what we understand
now is what happens is if Venus has a
runaway greenhouse effect and so let me
just explain briefly then what this
greenhouse effect is the atmosphere I
already mentioned a very important
function to this trivial piece
energy coming from the Sun but another
important function is that it functions
as a blanket it's transparent to the
visible radiation coming from the Sun
except for the presence of clouds but
it's not transparent to that energy
emitted by the surface of the planet
have much longer wavelengths so it it's
it's that's why it functions like a
mantle around the planet and that's what
explains this enormous temperature
difference in Venus and that's what
explains why in our planet here
surface is actually at +15 rather than -
18 degrees and degrees so that 33
degrees difference is what we call the
natural greenhouse effect and in fact
the minus 15 degree centigrade
temperature that we calculated is
correct except that it's not the
temperature of the surface which is what
we care about but it turns out to be the
temperatures roughly six or seven
kilometers above the Earth's surface
so the greenhouse effect from the part
of your fundamental physics is very well
understood what here is what worries us
the gases that absorb this infrared
radiation that was alluding to the
so-called greenhouse gases their
concentrations for some of them are
being affected by human activities and
we can see here how carbon dioxide it
concentrations has been changing with
time so there is a different
nomenclature that we normally use we
refer to the greenhouse effect we label
that whatever is changing as a
consequence of human activities what I
just explained before what happens in
Venus and these 33 degrees difference in
our planet is a natural greenhouse
effect but just a greenhouse effect
normally we use that phrase in
connection with these changes resulting
from human activities
now why is carbon dioxide increasing
first of all you see these natural
oscillations and that's because it's
biologically active respiration releases
carbon dioxide and photosynthesis
absorbs it so you see here the summer
winter variations in the concentration
the more pronounced ones are in the
northern hemisphere which is where the
bulk of the landmass exists in our
planet and the less pronounced ones in
the southern hemisphere where there is
less biological activity but what jumps
out here is this steady increase and we
know now of course where this is coming
from it's essentially from burning
fossil fuels roughly half of the carbon
dioxide which is a result of combustion
of these organic materials ends up in
the atmosphere the other half is
captured Parchin in the ocean oceans
partly by the land of plants and so on
so let me give you another perspective
for this changes I this cost carbon
dioxide now but if we look back for a
whole millennium the year a thousand to
two thousand and we look at the
concentration in this case of three
greenhouse gases here is carbon dioxide
here is methane and nitrous oxide
methane you can see also increasing very
recently where does it come from turns
out that methane is produced by
anaerobic processes bacterial processes
so a large source of methane comes from
ruminants from the gods of of cattle but
also from growing rice you have rice
paddies that that flooded with water so
this is indirectly a consequence of
human activities and it's all very
recent nitrous oxide is to a large
extent produced by using fertilizers
nitrogen fertilizer what is striking
then is that these curves have a similar
shape and the changes began then with
the Industrial Revolution well there is
one more curve that has a sort of
similar shape what we have here is
temperature temperature in our planet
and this is the average the mean surface
temperature is you have to measure it in
many places and then average it
the red line indicates direct
measurements but if we go back a whole
millennium there were no direct
measurements but there are ways to infer
what the temperature was from three
rings from corals from ice cores and
even from historical records so using
our best understanding of all these
pieces of information one can
reconstruct what the temperature was
here it's actually constrained to the
northern hemisphere where we have data
what what what is quite clear is that
you have this very recent temperature
jump so if we look at all the sets of
figures with we could we might suspect
that there is a connection between all
of them well what that connection turns
out to be rather complicated because the
climate system is complicated so what
I'm going to do is merely summarize it
and I'm going to use some of the
conclusions of this
so call IPCC group the intergovernmental
panel on climate change you can get here
a little bit of information convened by
the United Nations and so on which by
the way was established in a very
similar way to the way we dealt with the
ozone layer problem there there was an
international community of scientists
that provided assessments that were
meant to advise politicians and that's
how the Montreal Protocol came about
this is a similar process and this is
one of the conclusions they reached
comes from calculations like the ones
I'm going to describe briefly here one
way to look at the climate is through
models models of the climate that have
to take into account all sorts of
complications due the way the climate
functions difficult models to to build
that's only one tool there are several
other tools but with those models one
can compute temperature changes and this
is done for the last season I'd say in
this calculation from 1850 to the year
2000 and the lower line here is what is
calculated to happen if you do not take
into account these changes in the
chemical composition of the atmosphere
that I just showed you if however you
take that into account then you get
instead of this lower curve this other
curve and the upper line are the
observations so it's clear that these
calculations fit the observations much
better if you make a connection between
those changes in the composition and
what we expect to happen to the climate
if you have established or suspect at
least this cause effect relationship
then you can take one more step and then
you can predict what should the
temperature do in this century once you
make a connection between those two sets
of observations and what happens to the
temperature in this century will depend
on different scenarios that is it
depends how society evolves how the
economy moves and whether society
imposes restrictions on vinícius of
carbon dioxide and other greenhouse
gases or not what what is striking here
is that we have very significant
temperature changes compared to what has
happened
in the last thousand years and for that
matter in the last tens of thousands of
years as well so what do we do about
this first of all we have to ask the
question so what what happens if
temperature changes I will not discuss
this in any detail but you'll show it to
you there are in fact some beneficial
impacts of a warming of the Earth's
surface like you might have longer
growing seasons for for some crops in
some parts of the world but overall the
the effects that tend to be negative I'm
just talking about temperature but
rainfall will also change quite
significantly if indeed these greenhouse
gases have the effects that the
scientific community is assuming sea
level rise is yet another factor so you
have a multitude of potential effects
he'll the in fact that's one of the
expert thesis of dr. Sheehan but then
you have a recall chiral impacts and
that's Water Resources impacts obviously
if you change rain patterns the
consensus is that you might get because
of this temperature increase more
extreme events when it rains it pours
otherwise you have more droughts so it's
it's that's a logical consequence of
having more moisture in the atmosphere
at this point I should mention that
water vapor itself is a very important
greenhouse gas so human activities will
not directly change the amount of water
in the atmosphere or teeth through
changes in carbon dioxide the
temperature changes you have an
important feedback effect this water
vapor will in turn enhance the green
fire the greenhouse effect and that's
taken into account in these calculations
so you have other impact sea level rise
of course is very worrisome certain
countries will disappear completely the
small island countries what I'm doing
here I'll go through this very briefly
is just summarize what I've said so far
in terms of climate change we have
certain I should I would label these
facts the climate is clearly changing
very few people doubt that okay there
are most very concentrations of
greenhouse gases and other gases are
clearly changing also
that's very well-established what what
is perhaps less well establish but
certainly very logical is that these
changes have a connection and that human
activities are at least partly
responsible for this temperature
increase and this last point just tells
you the magnitude of these changes
between one-and-a-half and roughly six
degrees in this century and some deep
changes in the way this temperature is
distributed okay let me ask a question
here with this information what should
society do should society do something
about this problem I recognize that
there are uncertainties
what is it premature is it a matter of
opinion well let me clarify at least my
own thinking here we what scientists can
do is provide this type of information
but the actual answer to that question
does not live within the realm of
science it depends on your value
judgments it depends how you assess
risks but science kipo at least one step
further and I'm showing you here the
results of a some very interesting
calculations done by our colleagues here
at MIT in the Center for Global Change
science led by supreme what they have
done is calculated probabilities
since this changes in temperature rather
uncertain you can at least assess it's a
little bit subjective if you cannot do
this experiment we have only one planet
but you can calculate probabilities
based on what you think you know about
the system and here are the results two
curves one assuming that the society
society does something even if you do to
take actions right now you will have the
temperature change because we already
change the composition of the atmosphere
but if you continue just with business
as usual you will have much larger
changes and thank you you can analyze
this in any way you want for example
there is one chance in 40 that the
changes will be larger than 5 degrees
those would be very very large changes
they begin to become
to the changes between an ice age and an
interglacial our planet would really
look very different do you want to take
that risk again we don't make up one
planet what you don't have to all the
way to five what is most likely to
happen is something about two degrees
remind you that we already see half a
degree change and we see all these
consequences already but there is one
chance in twenty that you're gonna be
between three and four these are the
sort of risks that we normally don't
take if I tell you there is one chance
in 10 that you'll be stuck if you drive
in the snow only some of you might want
to drive but if I tell you that there's
one chance in in 10 that you don't have
a bad accident you probably want to the
driving unless you have a very strong
reason to do that so again this is not
within the realm of science considering
you were dealing with a planet and we're
dealing with these very important risks
and considering how many millions of
people will be affected in my own
personal opinion this is certainly
enough reason to start doing something
now because the risks are just too large
and just to highlight one more point
very briefly I talked about the average
temperature changes but the changes are
not evenly distributed with latitude you
see that at the poles you have some very
large changes that could have a very
important consequences for it for
example in terms of melting of the ice
caps again these are results from from
the group here at MIT I'm going to
transition now to the last problems that
I will deal with let me try to do that
fast but I'm still talking about climate
change and here is just a representation
of the forcing that means how much do we
expect on a relative basis different
factors to affect the climate and one
factor is the changes in the
concentrations of greenhouse gases which
for which we have a relatively high
level of scientific understanding and
the magnitude is reflected by this bar
co2 methane at war that's what I talked
about the halo Karma's are the CFCs
those are regulated because
of the stratospheric ozone problem
maneja and then at the other extreme we
have changes in the intensity of solar
radiation that we can do nothing about
or in between I mean we also have
stratospheric ozone but in between we
have all these other effects turns out
that they have to do with pollution they
have to do with air quality so it's
interesting that climate change is
actually connected with pollution so
what do we know about pollution air
pollution because it normally just a
regional or local problem we had
pollution like the episodes in London
that had to do with the sulphur in coal
that we knew was very damaging to people
many people actually died from from the
pollution events in the generation of
sulfuric acid and so on but the
pollution that we are not accustomed to
in recent years is what we call
photochemical air pollution that was
really first unraveled in Los Angeles
and we know but the ingredients of
pollution are hydrocarbons like from
from gasoline that are either directly
emitted or or gasoline that only
partially burned nitrous oxide and
sunlight the combination of the three
generates this type of pollution which
we know part of it is also the same
molecule that protects us in the
stratosphere it's actually nasty if you
have to breathe it in because it's very
active and it retains your lungs and
besides also the other component of
pollution are suspended particulate
matter that we also know has very
important health effects so just in
passing I know I have very little time
left but let me nevertheless just allude
to a program that were heavily involved
with that has to do with our pollution
in Mexico City were worried about
pollution in mega cities of the
developing world again because our many
cities now so pollution is happening in
many parts of the world and this
particular program what is interesting
about it is it doesn't mean just with
the science and technology of the
problem what we know that we have to
deal with social economic and pull
ethically issues as well to solve this
real-life problems in this case the
science itself is not in question we
know where the pollution comes from we
still have to do a lot of science to
refine our recommendations to the
government but it's very important to
work very closely with the governments
in this developing countries to make
sure that some improvements actually
take place and that has been the case in
Mexico City it's no longer the most
polluted city in the world but they're
still long distance to go but what I'm
talking about
recall is the context of global issues
what we have to do is to add to this
pollution coming out from many cities
recall that roughly half the population
of the world now its urbanized lives in
cities and the trend is increasing there
what we have to add another source of
pollution the same type of photochemical
pollution that comes from things like
forest fires but also agricultural
practices such as slash-and-burn
agriculture any time you burn organic
matter you're going to generate
hydrocarbons and nitrogen oxides that
will contribute to this making smoke and
making ozone in the atmosphere now what
we know now I'll just show very briefly
some satellite views of what happens to
this type of pollution in 98 we know
there were some forest fires in Mexico
you can see the plume from the satellite
clearly reaching the southern part of
the United States there were some large
pollution events in Asia again from from
forest fires in 97 and the health
effects were extremely large in in many
parts of Asia in this case in kuala
lumpur let me show you a more recent
event this is just this year in the the
end of January this is West Africa this
red dot this is a satellite picture but
this represent individual fires and you
can see the smoke really moving over the
ocean very clearly here from the
satellite pictures one more you can see
it here Asia core Japan Korea somewhere
here is Beijing and and Shanghai our
guess is somewhere around here
this gray color is pollution so there
are large amounts of pollution that lead
this is the same area you can see here
again Beijing and Shanghai some were
here covered by that so except for the
clouds all this gray mass is pollution
this is what leads to the so-called
brown cloud that are there worries that
it reaches the American continent as
well how do we know that well it turns
out there are other events that are also
very easily observed from satellites in
this case it's not directly pollution
like the one I was describing but dust
storms and their origin in this case is
there like the Gobi Desert which is also
indirectly been affected by human
activities the Gobi Desert is increasing
in size relatively fast so their
certification is another of those
problems that contributes to these
global issues and you can see here the
time scale for this dust clouds to reach
the American continent from Asia is
about six days it just how fast these
things moves and one last field up here
in terms of these pollution issues it's
also very interesting finding in this
case corns from this so-called
index experiment these were measurements
of the composition of air in this case
were shown measurements about a thousand
kilometers away from the Indian
continent in two air masses that are
relatively close to each other but one
is in the northern hemisphere namely
this one and one in the southern
hemisphere and if you recall as I
explained earlier the two hemispheres
are do not mix well so this represents
pollution coming from India in this case
you can clearly see the difference you
don't even see the horizon it's
pollution that has traveled a thousand
kilometers but the effect that is really
highlighted in this paper is cloudiness
turns out the important component of
this pollution is suit
these black carbon particles that turn
out talk when they are incorporated into
clouds a hitman and the clouds evaporate
so this is an example of an indirect
effect of pollution clouds play a very
important role in this energy balance of
the planet and you can either make more
clouds with with haze like force of uric
acid droplets or change their properties
in such a way as to compete with the
greenhouse effect or else like in the
case of soot you can add to the
greenhouse effect in terms of decreasing
cloudiness and increasing the amount of
energy that reaches the the surface of
the planet
so all these I can label us a global air
quality problem what I have here is just
a summary of I shared a few years ago
the National Academy panel which will
label global air quality to highlight
these types of issues the connection
between air quality and climate change
in this particular report we just made a
point that we don't have enough
observations in our planet to understand
clearly how these problems come about so
we should do more about it so I'm close
to to the end but I want to remind you
about this first a chart at the
beginning of constant methane constant
carbon dioxide and then certainly
increasing there is another curve that
you will probably know about that has a
similar shape human population in this
case I'll go back many millennia but we
are now close to 6 billion people or a
little bit above and this has all
happened very recently fortunately it's
leveling off ok it's not increasing at
this rate anymore but clearly all these
dramatic changes that I show you are a
consequence of this increasing human
population so let me just finish by
coming back to the ozone problem I want
to give you an example to see you how we
deal with these problems as I mentioned
we dealt with the status very course of
problem rather successfully here is an
example dealing with one CFC one that
happened to be used in the past to clean
electronic boards CFC 113 when we first
suggest that in the seventies that these
compounds had to be banned the
electronic industry got very worried
Japan was not willing initially
signed the Montreal Protocol as well but
it turns out the society is very
inventive so many patents came about to
develop these ports in different ways to
clean them even with water and soap
rather than with this more sophisticated
but excellent
solvents but the most interesting
technology shown here is one in which
you make clean electronic boards to
begin with so you do not need to use any
solvents so let me let me end up with
this view again just to highlight how
thin is our atmosphere and just to
summarize a perspective on all this of
course we know that people in the
developing world that they have they
have to increase their standard of
living they have the right to do that
and so the economy is need to grow but
it's clear that they should not grow
their economies the same way that we
have done it in the industrialized
country so far because our planet is not
large enough to absorb all these
unwanted side products of our activities
we have to learn to do it in different
ways
and so that's why it's imperative that
we all work together the industrial
sector the academic sector environmental
organizations that's how it happened
with the stratospheric ozone problem all
these sectors were together what we have
to do it once more because these new
technologies will not come out of the
developing world they don't have two
resources but at least with the ozone
story we have shown that it can be done
so there is light at the end of the
tunnel thank you
[Applause]
that was a wonderful talk Muriel and
it's a it's a great honor to be on the
program with my friend and colleague
Mario Molina
I want to thank Paul and Priscilla gray
for inviting me to be back at MIT where
I worked for 20 years until about two
years ago and in the medical department
I must confess that I have not started
using a PowerPoint I'm reluctant as
you'll see to part with things that have
worked so well for me I'm still using
thirty five millimeter slides and for
years I must confess I continued typing
on my IBM Selectric when others were
using word processors and I still drive
a 1986 Saab with over 200,000 miles on
it there was a slide that I believe
professor Molina may have dropped out of
his tray this is from that peer-reviewed
journal called the Weekly World News
couldn't resist that Mary we could turn
off this line so I'll get back to them
in a minute mm-hmm a minister in Montana
was was tired of working on his sermon
and he decided to go bear hunting and so
he drove to some nearby mountains and
hiked a trail and sat with his gun
loaded and after some hours a large
brown bear emerged and began to run
towards him the minister aimed his gun
and he pulled the trigger but the
trigger jammed and in a panic he began
to pray and he said O Lord I have always
been your faithful servant please Lord
please please make that bear a Christian
and at that moment the bear came to an
abrupt halt and it put its huge paws
together and it looked up at the sky and
said dear Lord
I thank thee for the gift I am about to
receive
now I tell this story because as you'll
see I'm generally rooting for the Bears
and because bears are totally unique and
remarkable creatures that hold enormous
ly important secrets for medicine as
I'll talk about shortly
now when I was on a flight from
Washington to Boston a couple of years
ago there was all of a sudden a great
commotion around me it turned out that a
large brown moth had somehow gotten onto
the plane and people being very startled
and afraid when it landed on them wanted
to kill it even the stewardesses
everyone was in a real frantic mood
somehow this unfortunate animal had
wandered in into the high-tech
relatively sterile world of humans where
it didn't belong and people were very
frightened of it even though it was
totally harmless and everyone was very
surprised when suddenly I stood up and
insisted that we catch the moth and let
it go I announced this very lard loudly
and I must confess I surprised myself
because I didn't realize I would do this
and I didn't have a very good idea of
how I was going to catch the moth but
then I thought of the vomit bag in front
of me and I blew it up and I went after
the moth I banged a fair number of heads
in the process and I released it after
we landed in Terminal B at Logan Airport
where the buses were spewing their
diesel fumes I'm not sure how much of a
favor this was but I was as you can
imagine savoring one of those few
moments in life when people ask who was
that masked man or perhaps in this case
who was that madman but I tell this
story because it illustrates it seems to
me how separated we've become from the
environment in which we live so
disconnected from the natural world
which increasingly exists as we become
more and more urbanized and zoos and
aquaria and Botanical Gardens so
disconnected that true nature like the
moths seemed to many an alien creature
as a hostile force to be conquered and
Exploited and even killed that the
environment has come to be for many
people an infinite resource that exists
for our use alone that we can take as
much as we want from or as an infinite
sink that we can dump as much as we want
into that somehow we can alter and
degrade the atmosphere in the oceans and
the forests and soils endangering
perhaps millions of species we share
this planet with some of which have been
on earth for hundreds of millions of
years longer than we have like sharks
and dragonflies and horseshoe crabs and
frogs as if somehow these alterations
had nothing whatsoever to do with us at
all as if we were totally insulated from
them and it seems to me that this lack
of connection to the environment this
fundamental failure to understand that
our health and lives depend on the
health of the global environment that
this problem is among the most important
problems we face in the years ahead
now what prevents us from recognizing
the threat that global environmental
change poses for us for one it's too
abstract it's too hard to relate to as
you heard professor Molino talking about
the atmosphere and the globe it occurs
over two largest scale it evolves too
slowly over time it's outside our
everyday experience especially for those
of us in rich nations like this one not
living at the margin of survival as
large numbers of people in developing
countries do all the time at the mercy
of every cyclone or crop failure global
environmental change is also too
frightening the specter of floods or
droughts or fires or famine or epidemics
of infectious disease they're too
overwhelming to contemplate there it
biblical in their proportions and for
the most part the problem see to seem
too large to solve making people feel
frightened or helpless or hopeless and
they'd rather just as soon think about
something else they're also very
complicated and technical the science is
very complicated and it's made worse it
seems to me by scientists and also
people in public health who write
and speak in jargon filled languages
unable to communicate with policy makers
or the media or the public so people
find it generally hard to too hard to
understand and it's also too
hypothetical it's only a theory in the
eyes of some skeptics a result of the
difficulty as Professor Molina talked
about of coming up with cause and proof
of cause and effect the reality that
their large natural fluctuations and the
fact that there's only one earth and we
never been in this situation before we
can't
there is no controlled subject for a
global experiments that are now taking
place no other earth where the variables
can be held constant so we have to rely
on computer models and projections that
are sometimes as you know less than
convincing for many it's also not worth
worrying about they believe if science
got us into this mess it's also going to
get us out well invent or synthesize or
engineer our way out of all of our
difficulties and while science has much
to offer we must be very humble and
fully aware of its limitations
especially in the face of understanding
highly complex nonlinear systems as you
heard professor Molina talking about
chlorofluorocarbons which were
originally greeted as the most wonderful
chemicals for refrigeration ever they
were not toxic like pneumonia they were
not flammable like propane the
refrigerants that were used at the time
and so chemically unreactive that no one
thought they would be an environmental
problem at all and furthermore in the
contrast in contrast to the issue of
nuclear weapons which I spent many years
working on where there were no changes
that we had to make in our lifestyle or
in personal choices to reduce the threat
of nuclear war with global environmental
change were all part of the problem and
were all part of this solution and many
of us including myself at times would
just as soon not think about or try not
to learn about the contribution our SUVs
or teak furniture or eating farm-raised
shrimp or Atlantic salmon both of which
by the way I love make too damaging the
environment and finally there are power
forces in some businesses some in the
fossil fuel industry some in timber and
mining and cattle farming and chemical
manufacturing and land development etc
and their political supporters including
some scientists some of whom are clearly
motivated by reasonable scientific
questions but others of whom represent
vested interests motivated by greed I'm
afraid to say who have attempted much as
the tobacco industry has done for
decades to suppress scientific findings
that raise health and safety questions
about their practices and products and
who have tried to undermine the
credibility of respected scientists and
public health experts and these skeptics
I'm sorry to say are often given equal
time by the media which loves a good
fight as if they represented objective
widely-held carefully researched equally
valid scientific viewpoints which they
do not so the public is often confused
and doesn't know what or whom to believe
well it was in recognizing the scope and
magnitude of these barriers that made it
difficult for people to grasp what human
activity was doing to the global
environment that we founded the center
that you heard professor gray mention at
Harvard Medical School believing somehow
that physicians and health professionals
that we could perhaps help translate
this abstract technical language of
environmental science into the concrete
personal terms of human health that we
hoped people could relate to and
understand and that by helping them
understand the potential risks to their
health and lives and to those of their
children we could perhaps help motivate
them to make the changes in their
personal lives and to support the
policies necessary to really protect the
global environment so I thought that
this evening I would go over one of the
main areas of interest at our Center at
the Medical School Harvard Medical
School and the area that I'm most
involved in that's the issue of loss of
biological diversity and its
implications for health
now when Homo sapiens evolved some
130,000 years ago the number of species
on earth was the largest ever but
human activity has resulted in species
extinction rates that are maybe a
hundred to even a thousand times those
of pre human levels causing Ed Wilson
and Paul Ehrlich and others to estimate
that we could lose maybe 22 for 25 to 40
percent or more of all plant and animal
species presently alive in the next 50
years and as many as two-thirds of them
by 2100 if these rates persist and it's
not just in the tropical rainforest but
in temperate regions as well like the
United States in this map the dark
states have the greatest loss of species
there's some 500 known animal and plant
species that are either missing or are
known to be extinct since the 17th
century and the greatest are found in
states like California and of course the
island of Hawaii and Alabama and these
the greatest losses are in some
freshwater species like mollusks and
crustaceans what's interesting is that
the United States is incredibly rich
biologically we lead the world in the
diversity of salamanders crayfish
freshwater turtles freshwater mollusks
we have the most sand species of mammals
and among the richest floor of any
temperate comfort country in the world
now the causes of species extinction are
many the main one is the degradation and
the reduction and the fragmentation of
habitats especially in species rich
areas like tropical rainforests and
coral reefs but we must be aware of
other factors as well such as global
warming and the associated changes in
global climate let me say a word about
this critical issue which professor
Molina has touched on 1998 was by far
the warmest year since 1856 when average
annual global surface temperature
temperatures were first accurately
measured this past year 2002 was the
second warmest 2001 was the third
warmest 1997 was the fourth warmest 1995
was the fifth warmest nine out of 10 of
the
warmest years on record since the mid
19th century have occurred since 1990
and it is clear from measurements that
we have that average global temperatures
have increased as professor Molina said
roughly 1 degree Fahrenheit since 1880
or so when the Industrial Revolution
began
now these projections that Professor
Molina mentioned on this this is the
last 20,000 years in IPCC 2 they were in
this range going up to say three and a
half degrees centigrade the IPCC has so
far raised that at the upper limit to go
as high as 11 degrees Fahrenheit as
Professor Molina mentioned that degree
of change is the difference between the
end of the last ice age some 20,000
years ago and now and at the end of the
last ice age where we're sitting in this
lecture room we were under a layer of
ice a mile thick so we're talking about
huge huge changes in temperature now
what's important for species is not just
the magnitude of this change but the
rate of it and it will is thought to be
somewhere between 10 and a hundred times
greater than temperature warming's in
the past posing great risks to species
now why is this
well the fossil record shows that
climate change was the dominant factor
in the great extinctions of the past
both warming and cooling directly
because the temperature shifts were
outside the range as to which species
could adapt but indirectly because of
changes in habitat formation of glaciers
changes in sea level etc with warming
species on land and in the oceans move
towards the poles their ranges change
and on land they also move to higher
altitudes and with cooling they moved
back towards the equator and to lower
altitudes those that couldn't shift fast
enough or because there were barriers to
their movement of their range change
were lost now there's a much faster rate
of change predicted and their barriers
everywhere that humans have created
farms and cities and roads
cetera now you recall in that previous
graph that the temperature has changed
roughly 1 degree Fahrenheit so the
question is can we see any evidence of
biological changes with this small
degree of temperature increase on
average and the answer seems to be yes
there are two major reports in nature in
the last month or so that are showing of
what are called fingerprints of
biological ecosystem change from climate
change and these are events like the
earlier arrival of migratory birds or
were frog breeding earlier spring
flowering early budding and trees and
also changes in the ranges of animals
like I mentioned for example this is
what's called Edith's Checkerspot
butterfly it's a butterfly that's in the
western part of the United States and in
the last several decades its range it's
been followed very closely butterflies
and birds are very closely studied by
biologists mostly because they're
beautiful in part and its range has
moved northward in the western United
States it's been tracked for decades and
the same has been true with vascular
plants moving to higher altitudes in the
Alps these are both very carefully done
studies in the literature now there are
other factors clearly besides climate
change that lead to threats to species
one of them of course is toxic chemicals
which may lead to reproductive or
endocrine or immunologic or
developmental effects and they may cause
species loss like in this study with a
frog species that grow extra limbs and
of course that affects reproduction it's
etc and of course invasive species like
the zebra mussel or the purple
loosestrife or others which affect
species survival and finally the the
just the wanton slaughter of many
species such as these gorillas at
Western Africa which along with chimps
and other primates are being killed for
bush meat to feed loggers and and miners
but also native tribes many of which are
very hungry and poor won't get into it
but one of the it's it's quite strongly
believed now
in the scientific community that the
source of hiv/aids came from the
subspecies of chimpanzee in Cameroon
from bushmeat exposure that is exposure
to blood over several last several
decades and and has led to catastrophe
as you as you know now what does all
this have to do with human health well
for one with the loss of species we're
losing the possibility of discovering
new medicines because over the course of
billions of years of evolution species
have developed chemicals that they need
to fight infections and tumors and and
other diseases and also to capture prey
and avoid being eaten and some of these
chemicals have become some of today's
most important pharmaceuticals this is
what's called the cinchona tree in the
Amma's from the Amazon and gave us
quinine and another compound called
quinidine quinine is a major anti
malarial it was the original anti
malarial it's making a comeback as some
of the plasmodia from malaria are
developing resistance to that synthetic
squint Adeem is used to treat cardiac
disease but temperate species have also
given us enormous li useful drugs the
wonder drug aspirin was originally
derived from Salus Ilyn extracted from
the willow tree which really everybody
in this room over 50 unless it's
contraindicated for other reasons like a
bleeding disorder should be taking one
aspirin every other day there's
extremely robust data in in the
literature that this prevents heart
attacks and strokes and just in the last
week there have been two published
studies about aspirin this incredible
drug that it protects it's thought to
protect against throat and mouth cancer
and in today's new york times to prevent
the growth of precancerous polyps in the
colon which is a major killer another
temperate source of drugs is from these
flowers called foxglove this is a
picture from my garden they this flower
gave us digitalis and also which is
widely used in
stir in synthetic analogues to treat
congestive heart failure and atrial
fibrillation indeed a study showed that
of the hundred and fifty most prescribed
drugs in the United States more than
half of them were either derived from or
patterned after compounds derived from
natural sources and of course as you
know in the developing world some 80
percent of people rely on traditional
medicines from mostly from plants I want
to talk about this species this genus
they're called cone snails these are
extremely beautiful shells they've been
collected for centuries
I've brought great deals of money and in
during the Renaissance in Holland and in
fact one one cone snail was sold at an
auction for more than a Vermeer painting
in 1796 they were so highly prized
what's incredible about these there's
some 500 species they're predatory
snails they mostly live in tropical
coral reefs in the South Pacific and
they feed by and defend themselves by
firing a poison coated harpoon and this
spike contains a cocktail of toxins they
paralyze their prey worms and mollusks
and fish these are small peptides much
like the peptides that are found in the
toxins of snakes and scorpions and
spiders and sea anemones but in cone
snails they are truly amazing there are
500 species each species is thought to
contain a hundred distinct peptide toxin
so there may be as many as fifty
thousand peptide toxins only a hundred
have been characterized from three
species and of these hundred want to
tell you about one in particular which
is what's called a voltage sensitive
calcium channel blocker you may know
about another calcium channel blocker
which is used in the treatment of angina
or high blood pressure called kalyan or
our verapamil this calcium channel
blocker does two remarkable things that
have been studied one is it blocks a
cascade of biochemical reactions
have been mediated by the influx of
calcium and that starts the death of
nerve cells when there hasn't been
enough circulation so this is a
tremendous interest in in coronary
bypass surgery and following head
injuries but it also oh this is firing
this harpoon on a fish but it also binds
to the incoming nerve cells and what's
called the dorsal Horn of the spinal
cord with enormous specificity and
blocks the transmission of pain up these
neurons without blocking fine touch now
what's amazing about this particular
synthetic drug that's coming from the
toxin is that it's been shown to be a
thousand times more potent than morphine
but unlike morphine it doesn't cause
addiction or the development of
tolerance this is an enormous problem in
treating chronic pain in people with
nerve injuries or cancer or AIDS HIV
AIDS because what happens is you need
more and more drug to get the same
effect because of the development of
tolerance this particular toxin
developed drug does not seem to cause
that other cone snail toxins are being
developed for epilepsy that doesn't
respond to other epileptic medications
and for the treatment of a kind of lung
cancer that has been so far unresponsive
to other treatments but yet cone snails
are endangered their shells are
collected both for marine curios and
also for unfortunately for medical
research there's very little regulation
but mostly cone snails live on coral
reefs and coral reefs are endangered
around the world particularly in parts
of the South Pacific where they are
mostly found now species loss doesn't
only lead to a loss of potential
medicines it affects medical research in
major ways I mentioned about bears and
bear populations are threatened in many
parts of the world because of
destruction of their habitat but also
because of overhunting secondary to the
high prices their organs reputed to have
medicinal value bring in Asian black
markets bear gall bladders for example
are highly sought after
there-there are worth 18 times their
weight in gold and there's a flourishing
black market trade in bare parts and
parts of South Korea and China and here
in Thailand and yet the tragedy is that
living bears are worth far more than the
sum of all their body parts let me
explain why in winter months Bears enter
a three to seven month period of
hibernation it's really Denning they
don't fully hibernate as some rodent
species do there their heart rate drops
and their temperature drops but they are
fully arousal as some bear biologists
have discovered to their dismay despite
a lack of weight bearing for months
Denning Bears don't lose bone mass they
don't develop osteoporosis a phenomena
that occurs in every other mammalian
species including humans with decreased
mechanical use of the skeleton
osteoporosis is an enormous problem in
the inactive elderly especially
postmenopausal women and paralyzed
patients and understanding how bears
prevent it there's a lot of research
going on prevent their bones from being
resorbed could lead to new ways of
preventing and treating this disease
which afflicts 28 million people in the
United States alone results in a 1.5
million bone fractures and about 70,000
deaths every year cost the US economy
thirteen point eight billion dollars a
year in medical costs and lost
productivity Bears also don't eat drink
urinate or defecate for periods of up to
seven months
if we don't urinate for a few days we
die they are able to recycle their
urinary waste they make new protein they
they have a pathway that we don't fully
understand they recycle everything and
kidney failure in the United States cost
the US economy an additional 16 billion
dollars a year the only way to treat
someone with terminal kidney disease is
dialysis or kidney transplant we have no
other treatment
you just say a quick word about polar
bears which are endangered for yet
another reason not just destruction of
their habitat which from things like oil
exploration and drilling and habit and
in the Arctic National Wildlife Refuge
where they live but also over hunting
some hunters pay up to twenty two
thousand dollars to bag a polar bear on
expeditions but they're also being
endangered by climate change which as
Professor Molina said is not uniform is
greatest at the at Bora in boreal
regions and at the poles and this is an
enormous problem for bears because ice
thins they depend on ice to hunt seals
and that's their main food if there's no
ice the seals can surface anywhere far
from from the polar bears just one quick
thing before moving on I know I'm over
time a little bit other species don't
only teach us about medical things but
teach us other secrets this is a
straight the strange building is from
Harare Zimbabwe it's modeled after the
venting and air circulation dynamics
that are found in termite nests termites
it turns out our farmers and they grow a
fungus in the middle of their nests and
they have to keep the fungus at a
constant 87 degrees Fahrenheit plus or
minus a half a degree despite very wide
fluctuations outside in this part of
Africa some can get to be 35 degrees
Fahrenheit at night and over a hundred
and four degrees during the day this
Harare building is modeled after those
dynamics of of airflow and humidity and
uses one-tenth the energy that a
building of its size would use for
heating and cooling now finally I want
to talk about the whole issue of
ecosystem services and that is the ways
that species interact to provide
valuable life support for all of us for
all living things they maintain global
temperatures and precipitation by
storing carbon they regulate atmospheric
concentrations of oxygen and carbon
dioxide and water vapor they break down
ways
and dead organisms they return the
nutrients to the land and the oceans
they pollinate plants etc etc etc we
don't know a great deal about how some
of these ecosystems functions work let
me talk about one of them from a human
point of view and that is to hold
infectious agents in the environment in
check so they from our perspective don't
cause significant human disease this is
a map of Lyme disease cases and in the
United States each dot represents a case
and you can see of course the enormous
concentration in the Middle Atlantic and
New England and some in the Upper
Midwest spattering of cases in
California and parts of the of the
southeast what you notice well let me go
it's Lyme disease is carried it's the
most common vector borne disease in the
United States they're about 19,000
reported cases probably many others that
aren't reported it's carried by the
black legged tick in the east it's it
carries a bacteria a spirochete
also involved in the disease are the
white-tailed deer and also the
white-footed Mouse I'm sorry to say this
is a deer mouse but I didn't have a
picture of a white footed Mouse we are
an accidental host and it's long been
observed as I mentioned that they're not
that many cases in the western part of
the United States even though there are
ticks and there are spirochete and there
are deer and there are mice it turns out
one of the favorite meals for the tick
out west is something called the Western
fence lizard and it's blood contains a
substance that kills the bacteria many
species of reptiles are threatened and
one has to ask what happens if we lose
the Western fence lizard to the Lyme
disease incidents out west but another
issue is quite interesting and that is
in areas where there's little biological
diversity like in islands like Martha's
Vineyard and Nantucket great rates of
infection are very high and some very
elegant work by one of my colleagues
Rick ah spelled has shown that when
there's a great deal of biological
diversity of vertebrates in the forest
then the chances of getting Lyme are
less
and the reasons are quite interesting
one is that that the ticks bite anything
they find that they come across so
they're not only biting the mouse and
the deer which keep our part of the
cycle
they're also biting other vertebrates
they're biting birds they're biting
amphibians are biting whatever crosses
their path and these other animals are
in what are called incompetent hosts
they don't keep the life cycle of the
lawn going so there's a dilution of
what's called a dilution effect of the
bacteria and we're less likely to get
Lyme if there are lots of different
other animals in the forest
but what also happens is that some of
these other animals are competing with
the the main host the mouse for food so
they keep its population down and some
of them are predators so an example
where biological diversity keeps the
risk of Lyme low now what does all this
mean and what can be done and I may be
putting on my more activist hat in this
section that I I will wear it gently I
must tell you that I am I came back from
London late last night so it is now what
is it for 8:30 well five hours later so
after one o'clock I'm not responsible
for anything I think or say so well for
one we we have to look at these problems
directly without avoidance and denial no
matter how difficult or even frightening
they are in order to begin to solve them
we can't bury our heads in the sand or
say it's up to others we must help
people in the business world and in
politics to see that it's it's not a
choice between a healthy environment or
a health or healthy profits one can have
both indeed without a healthy
environment the cost to society from the
impacts on agriculture and private
property and human health will be so
enormous as to affect
every aspect of the marketplace and as
we did with the Montreal Protocol as as
Professor Molina said that protected the
ozone layer the United States as the
most powerful player on the world stage
as the greatest consumer of resources
and producer of waste we must take the
lead in world efforts to reduce
greenhouse gases and to protect
biological diversity we have not even
signed and ratified the Convention on
Biological Diversity which almost every
other country in the world has we don't
have a seat at the table at the
convention and as you know while a
hundred and seventy eight nations agreed
last year to curb greenhouse gas
emissions including all of our allies
the United States with four to five
percent of the world's population
producing 25 percent of the world's
human released greenhouse gases sat on
the sidelines and in my view this should
be a matter of national disgrace and
great embarrassment and it may be said
that those who are blocking these
efforts by I believe deliberately
misrepresenting the science in some
cases and trying to discredit people on
the National Academy of Sciences or the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change like unfortunately some members
of our administration and some in
Congress who have I'm afraid appallingly
meager understanding of the environment
or of Public Health and I'm afraid also
and this is where I'm they get into
trouble but some multinationals like
ExxonMobil which in their bi-weekly
infomercials in the New York Times talk
about climate change science in an often
very misleading way or some quote think
tanks like the George C Marshall
Institute or the Competitive Enterprise
Institute it may be said of them as
Teddy Roosevelt once said of his
political opponents quote that every
time they open their mouths on these
issues they subtract from the sum total
of human knowledge end of quote
and we should not be surprised to learn
that our species Homo sapiens has been
found to contain some Neanderthal
genetic material well so much for my
rant we can and we must invest
scientific effort and money on a scale
similar to the Manhattan Project to
develop renewable non-polluting sources
of energy solar and wind and geothermal
new batteries greater efficiency why
isn't the United States leading in these
technologies I'm afraid to say why isn't
MIT leading in these technologies isn't
it clear that those who succeed in
developing inexpensive efficient
renewable energy sources will be the
next Microsoft the next Intel we must
control the discharge of pollutants
particularly those that are long-lasting
and accumulate in the food chain like
some heavy metals and some persistent
organic pollutants we must as you saw
professor Molina slide control or slow
down population growth by supporting
efforts to provide access to family
planning to every woman who wants it and
by increasing educational and career
opportunities for women around the world
we need to protect biologically rich
ecosystems like tropical rainforests and
coral reefs and let me say just a quick
word about these one of the greatest
crimes against the environment has been
the draining and destruction of
marshlands of southern Iraq by Saddam
Hussein and the destruction of the 6,000
year old culture of the Marsh Arabs
which developed the arch thousands of
years before the Romans but it is a
tragic irony that the u.s. Army Corps of
Engineers with the blessing of the Bush
administration has begun to redefine
what constitutes a wetland so that plans
are now in the works to drain hundreds
of thousands of acres of wetlands across
coastal Mississippi in parts of Texas so
that they can be developed and I should
say if there is a war in Iraq it will be
devastating not just for the tens of
thousands of Iraqi civilians
or the thousands perhaps of American and
British young people but for the
environment we must ourselves be models
for responsible healthy sustainable
environmental practices by reducing and
reusing and recycling resources do we
really need every gadget that the newest
sharper image catalog shows us I believe
we need to drive small cars that's my
wife Jake standing next to this little
Fiat she is 511 she would kill me if she
knew I was showing this picture rather
than this one god I hope this is not
made by Ford Motor Company I don't think
I don't think so I think it's a
Chevrolet oh I feel another rant coming
on let me just say a quick word about
SUVs they consume two or three times as
much gasoline as a compact sedan they
give off five times more air pollutants
they give there are three times more
likely to kill the other driver in an
accident and two to four times more
likely to roll over when hit but I'm
delighted to say that Ford Motor Company
is taking a really leadership role in
developing safer and more fuel-efficient
SUVs and working on fuel cell vehicles
and I'm very proud of that clearly one
of the moves is to look at hybrid
vehicles this is the Honda Insight which
gets roughly 60 miles to a gallon and
some tests but better yet take public
transportation or bike or walk and there
are other ways we can reduce our
consumption of energy we can better
insulate our homes we can use more
energy-efficient lighting if every
household in California had replaced
just four 70 watt 75 watt light bulbs
with available compact fluorescent bulbs
the state would not have had to build
three new
average power plants average size power
plants and in the energy crunch and this
should be somebody's PhD thesis in this
room in nineteen 2001 during the
blackouts and brownouts in California
the state residents reduced electrical
use by eleven percent without a
significant change in their quality of
life who is studying this who is
cataloging this this is not rocket
science these technologies are available
now we need to engage in a whole array
of individual and collective actions
that preserve biodiversity and the
environment and we need to be a model
for others it's hard to be one to tell
family and friends that they shouldn't
eat that piece of swordfish one is not
generally invited to too many more
family parties but it is important to to
say politely and without being
condescending or environmentally holier
than now some things like that we can
eat low on the food chain we should
avoid marine species that are endangered
like orange roughy and Chilean sea bass
which was renamed it's really Patagonian
toothfish we shouldn't eat these they're
endangered fish the Monterey Bay
Aquarium puts out a list of fish that
are not endangered that you can eat we
should stay away I'm sorry to say
because I love them from farm-raised
carnivorous salmon it takes seven pounds
of fish meal to make one pound of farm
raised salmon and you can buy frozen
wild caught salmon from the Pacific
Northwest in Alaska you can buy
herbivorous catfish or tilapia you
should anyway be eating low on the food
fish web because higher you go the more
likely you are to be exposed to
pollutants which get bio accumulated we
should eat less red meat it's not good
for the environment and it's not good
for you either
and if you do buy meat buy organic meat
because then you won't be getting growth
hormones or antibiotics or pesticides
and buy organic food anyway because food
from local farmers at farmers markets
this will encourage organic food
practices and keep these farmers trying
to preserve the environment
in business and try to avoid I'm sorry
to say because it has effects on the
developing world but buying produce that
had to fly 5,000 miles to get to you you
should be buying as much as you can I
know it's not always possible things
that are local don't buy tropical
hardwoods like teak or mahogany unless
it's clear that these are being raised
sustainably and asked about that Home
Depot is selling certified wood products
and you can also buy recycled wood it's
available in many areas for construction
and save energy clearly as you've heard
professor Molino say global warming will
become in synergy with other sources the
predominant factor in coming decades for
species loss when the environmentalists
and Cape Cod and the islands protest the
wind generating towers saying they'll
harm marine species and birds I agree
that we need to study this and mitigate
these effects but are they considering
the effect on climate change on marine
species and birds and what other
practical suggestions do they have to
reduce our greenhouse gas emissions and
still meet our energy needs all of you
we can reduce our own energy use for
God's sakes turn off the lights in rooms
that are empty turn down the thermostat
at night wear a sweater walk bike take
the train
above all we need to become fully
informed about these issues and help
others understand them it's not too late
to apply the brakes this is a real
picture in the garden upon us and in
Paris where this train unfortunately did
not apply its brakes in time please to
say our Center has focused all of our
energies on trying to achieve some of
these goals we have taught a course for
six years at Harvard Medical School
called human health and global
environmental change professor Molina
has spoken in the course on ozone
depletion at Wilson on loss of
biodiversity we bring people from all
over the country and world to speak it's
open to students at MIT and you'll be
there with Harvard Medical Students
students from the Harvard School of
Public Health the Kennedy School and
other
schools it's very highly ranked and it's
also completely online on our website
all the lectures a streaming video all
the readings as PDF files anyone in the
world with at least a 56k modem can take
the entire course free of charge and
hundreds have around the world we do
work on the Congress we've held eight
congressional briefings so far the last
one on bush meat and primates and and
hiv/aids with Jane Goodall that's also
completely on our website every year in
the spring we hold an intensive course
on the environment and health for
congressional staffers which has become
very popular and because of that we've
been asked to design a course for
broadcast meteorologists on television
and radio about the links of climate and
weather to the environment and human
health were working on an exhibit at the
New England Aquarium on oceans and
health and were working on this project
with the United Nations on biodiversity
and human health well I want to close
with a final personal comment I believe
we are incredibly lucky to be alive at
this moment in history for the changes
to the environment that I've spoken
about are caused by our own behavior and
we have the ability our generation
especially those of us in the most
powerful country on the planet
especially those of us in this room who
are among the most privileged and
influential members of this society we
have the ability to turn these changes
around and that in destroying other
species and ecosystems and degrading the
global environment in which we all live
we're doing something that is not just
morally wrong it is deeply and
shamefully ignorant for we're tampering
with life-support systems of the planet
with the physical and chemical and
biological systems of this earth in ways
we barely understand that are bound to
have profound consequences for the
health and lives of our children
and for all children to come we can and
we must protect this incredibly wondrous
gift that we have been given and I urge
all of you to join me and my colleagues
in this effort thank you
Mary oh and Eric thank you very very
much we've had here this evening lucid
descriptions of the issues that face us
six billion of us and what we are doing
to our environment and we've had clarion
calls to what we must the way the ways
in which we must take action I hope that
all of us as we leave here tonight will
think on on those calls to action and
push in directions that will ameliorate
the changes we are forcing six billion
of us on the environment for our
children and grandchildren we have a few
minutes for questions here there are two
microphones one in the foot of each
aisle this is being videocast
so I'd appreciate it as people who want
to speak would come down to the
microphones and Professor Molina and dr.
Simeon will respond yes sir if you could
just say a word about some of the
scientists and I know they're a
relatively small man minority who would
dispute some of your findings and I'd
also like to ask if you think that one
of the main reasons why people don't
realize what's going on the average
person is because they think that
science is black and white and they
don't understand that in general science
is always in a state of flux and there's
an old saying that it only advances one
funeral at a time and so how can this
kind of information reach the public
because if everyone in the public we're
here listening to you tonight no doubt
they would feel very differently if they
understood what the scientific consensus
is the vast majority of scientists and
how they think okay I think this is a
question we should both answer but let
me give a brief first answer I think
part of the explanation is there are of
course some scientists that have some
special interests okay that's what maybe
you can explain part of their behavior
because they want to protect those
interests but there are other scientists
that appear to be in in good faith the
question what
the sort of things that we talk about
and to to in my opinion some of this
apparently divergent ways of responding
to what's going on around us have to do
with the one of the points I try to make
of what designs have got this not
science for example in order to assess
the question whether they should worry
about these issues you also have to take
into account what are the consequence of
certain actions will the economy suffer
well if we talk about uncertainties in
the science there are even larger
uncertainties in terms of how the
economy will respond to suggested
changes from the example with CFCs there
were people that worried that millions
of jobs would be lost and billions of
dollars would be lost that turned out
not to be the case so in my own personal
experience that was exaggerated but
something similar is can certainly
happen with a climate change issue with
biodiversity I guess much of it is with
the ignorance there are not many people
that are sufficiently well-informed to
realize how much in travel we are as a
doctor simian really explained very
clearly I didn't mean to employ in any
way the scientists who who disagree with
some of the things I said or or not
doing that out of valid scientific
questions clearly they're there many
that are I do I do believe that with the
issue of climate change and loss of
biodiversity there's there's pretty
great consensus in the scientific
community that these are real problems
and great agreement about what what is
at stake but I want to tell you an
anecdote which was really quite
revealing to me I I go to the Congress a
few months before designing this course
for congressional staffers and one of
the aides in giving his ideas about what
lectures we should hold mention that we
should go to this one of the think tanks
that I mentioned and and bring in one of
the other views on climate change to
balance out the view that we might have
from someone who was part of the inter
government governmental panel and one of
the things he said I found rather very
disturbing and it revealed to me how
little understanding there is about the
way of the working of science and how
science should really advise policy he
said well that person has as much a
valid as valid of you hadn't published
anything in the peer-reviewed literature
but has a strongly held view and it's
equally valid to someone say from the
IPCC or the National Academy and he said
it's just a point of view it's a belief
system that is a science is one belief
system and another sceptical point of
view that is not necessarily based on
science is an equally valid belief
system and I think that really is our
fault because if there's that much this
is a fairly senior aide in a very senior
office in the Senate if there's that
much misunderstanding about how science
works because as you have have said
Mario and I think you've implied the the
uncertainty is interpreted as a point of
view you know that if it's science is
not true if you can't prove cause and
effect then you really have no more
reason to state that view than someone
who has a different point of view I
think we're not doing a terribly good
job in communicating with policymakers
or the public and I think we really need
to think more about how to how to do
that in a way that is is understandable
and because of this view we're going to
have a whole morning session about but
how science works how hypotheses are
tested the issue of uncertainty because
I think there was so little
understanding of the role of science
yes please it's it's a great you know
honor to be here because I've taken
classes with both of you I'm a student
of both of you one of the things that
you know often was brought up in the
course at Harvard as well as you know
brought up again and again in the
scientific community dealing with
environmental issues is the role of the
media in communicating information to
the general public raising awareness and
of course connected to that is the role
that scientists have to play in making
sure you know correct information and
easily understandable information is
given to the media and that there seems
to be a certain degree of
misunderstanding how that should be done
scientists somehow think that your
science is so clear that the facts are
so clear they've just put it out there
and you know I'm media person from New
York Times or Newsweek whatever will
pick it up and be able to deliver the
right way could you say a little bit
about the responsibility of people who
are studying this field in actually
taking time out and spending time with
the media or you know having an outreach
to really make people understand not
just the fact that science is factual
and based on experiments done but also
that it actually relates to everyday
lives okay let me start with some
comments there I agree with you we
scientists too have a responsibility to
communicate particularly with the media
because that's one way to communicate
with the public that is however some
sort of tradition which I think is
disappearing but the tradition in the
old way of doing science is to consider
yourself above the masses and so you
develop a language that only your peers
can understand sort of the ivory tower
image if you exaggerate that that's even
for this sort of thinking comes that if
your science has some sort of
application it becomes dirty it's no
longer pure science as if though there's
a pure and impure science okay but in
any event I'm very much in the agreement
with you that it's important to be able
to communicate your science particularly
the science can have impacts too
Society and one more point which
actually connects this view with us been
working at universities I'll try to
teach I think if you really understand
well some of the problems that you're
dealing with you should be able to put
it in plain language it does require a
very clear understanding and it's not
easy you have to work at that but I
guess we both have spent quite a bit of
time talking to reporters and we learn
how to communicate with them fortunately
at least here in the United States now
they are societies of environmental
journalists but it takes time it takes
an effort that you have to develop some
sort of a connection with them so it's a
continued effort we cannot give that up
but we should really train all our
students to be aware of the problem and
to try to be able to explain their
findings in common language I think it's
it's an important improvement
I totally agree and there is a group
called the National Association of
science writers it's quite large it has
its annual meeting during the triple-a s
meetings and there also is this
environmental science writer group
they're very interested in speaking with
people in the sciences in public health
and and as as Professor Molina said I
think we need to be very cognizant of
the language we use so that they can
really understand that there's almost
nothing more important than that in my
view because they are reaching millions
of people but I did want to go back to
this point I made before I think there's
something sort of fundamentally amiss
with some of the reporting about science
and about any issue because the media in
many ways is structured to have opposing
views Nightline as the is the prime
example so so that someone from the
National Academy of Science talking
about climate change will be debating
someone like Rush Limbaugh and and and
that kind of fight that kind of sort of
polar opposite polarizing of view
is something that our media and I think
not just our media that other media tend
to lean to because it's sort of it's its
watch journalism I mean we can see it on
what's that program where everyone's
shouting at each other all the time that
so that kind of polarization of views
tends to give the impression to the to
the viewer that these are two equally
valid viewpoints even if one is very far
over to one side and that's a real
problem I think in terms of public
understanding last question at this
microphone hi I know that where I live
for one we seem to heat our rooms with
the air exhausted from the cooling fans
or Pentium 4 Linux boxes and I was maybe
curious on a couple counts that um first
I was wondering if either of you ever
had any personal guilt attacks that
something you're doing was being
environmentally destructive driving this
song may be better than driving an SUV
but but it could be still better it
could be definitely be far still better
i retrofit that saw with fuel cell
engines but I was wondering first if
there are any personal guilt attacks
that you had experienced in that regard
and on the other hand if there is
anything really even anything anecdotal
that you consider a considered
noteworthy situation you have personally
ameliorated let me start with I'll just
make the statement I have had killed
attacks but there are many things we can
do personally however what I worried
about in terms of having the most impact
possible on the way things function is
to communicate directly with our
decision-makers that doesn't mean we
still shouldn't do personal things like
doctors even very eloquently hood but
some of the roots of the problem say you
mention about some situations with
energy some of the roots of the problem
is that energy is just far too cheap
because it's not
really considering the actual costs of
environmental effect so it's what we
call externalities and they can be
varied so just to give you an example
how I sort of counteract hisskill the
tax i'm belong to a group now an Energy
Commission which is nonpartisan we have
people from from all spectra industry
Republicans Democrats and so on and one
of the achievements of this group and I
must say I'm an advocate in that group
is to come up with with the
recommendations such as this one that
energy should be more expensive that's
not poss and go along the current
thinking of the administration what if a
group like this makes strong statements
and it's clearly not not an extreme
liberal leftist group I expect it to
have a large impact so to me that's an
important action but there are lots of
things personally that like we should be
doing perhaps I should let Eric do the
other part well if I didn't make this
clear before I'm a psychiatrist
I practice clinically it's always very
difficult to ask a psychiatrist how he
or she is feeling about anything and if
you ask us about guilt
let me tell you no I clearly I I mean I
used to drive my car to work until my
wife shamed me and and you know we have
a battle I turn off lights in the room
but she walks everywhere so now I walk
everywhere clearly all of us can do
things better but but I actually think
guilt is not a good motivator for change
I think if you speak to an audience and
you make everybody feel guilty about
what they're doing that's not gonna get
anywhere I think people get their backs
up they get defensive they rationalize
what they're doing or they turn you off
so I don't think that is a good way and
you know we've struggled with this and
the work we've done with nuclear weapons
and with the environment I think what
even people need to hear is that one the
situation is not hopeless there are
things that we can change and there are
things that will have great benefit and
value and that all of us are a part of
the solution and that added collective
value has great benefit for society so I
think that's a much better way of
approaching these issues but since I
have the floor still I would like to
propose since if I remember from my late
teens and early 20s I loved competition
and was competitive and I would love to
see MIT dorms compete for who can have
the best recycling program which dorm
can use the least amount of energy per
capita why not have something like that
or which dorm at MIT can use less energy
per capita than a dorm at heart
or Caltech - two quick matters before we
adjourned the next lectures in this
series the Ford MIT series will occur
here on that not in this room but on the
23rd of September the two speakers will
be - Institute professors Philip sharp
the Department of Biology and Jerome
Friedman from the department of physics
and the title is national security
issues and the impact on research there
is a reception following this meeting in
the bush lobby building 13 Lobby which
is about 50 feet in that direction if
you go out into the corridor behind me
and go down the stairs at the end of
that corridor it'll bring you right into
the bush lobby please join me once again
in thanking our speakers
you